[Applause]
[Music]
how many of you folks have used plated
before so uh some but not that many sent
least we have a good opportunity to go
sign up yeah to evangelize a little bit
but in a nutshell just give the
high-level description of what the
company is or so for the consumer and
happy I think we're gonna talk a bunch
about the you know the business side for
the consumer we we help you cook so
we're a meal kit business we deliver all
that portion ingredients you need to
cook at home along with recipe content
paper recipe cards video content etc got
it and you guys have raised roughly 90
million dollars you have how you do you
say how many customers you've had I
think all that sorry I think all the
lawyers will let me say at this point is
a few hundred thousand okay and you guys
recently sold a year ago a little over a
year ago for a roughly roughly three
hundred million dollars to Albertsons
right correct so these guys have an
amazing story because similar to give
you when we're talking before it
happened very quickly what year we use
guys started started so I've won
co-founder we started the business in
the summer of 2012 and then sold in the
summer of 2017 so five years which may
be as quick
I suppose in terms of you know venture
backed companies it is but definitely
didn't feel that quick and it never
feels fast when you're doing it every
day so I want to hear about the early
story cuz you and I talked about it a
few days ago week ago and you're talking
about just the early the first iteration
of the product I found to be kind of
shocking actually it was pretty it's a
pretty amazing story so walk me through
where you were a few months before
starting the business and what led you
to let's say the the the first month of
the company so that the kind of genesis
of the company was we started out my
co-founder nick and i knowing that we
wanted to work together but not on what
so it was team first an idea second
which i think is a reasonably good way
to go about it what a lot of the you
know academics would tell you is the
number one thing that kills startups is
co-founder conflict I've certainly seen
it you know with friends and
you know sort of folks that run into so
that part was very important to get
right so then after we decided that we
were gonna work together we sat down and
looked each other and went well what now
we need to figure out what the idea is
and tried to go through a process of
figuring out you know what was both
interesting to us so it's kind of that
you know p-word
what are we passionate about but you
know there's lost things that we were
passionate about that it would probably
be horrendous businesses so what are we
actually interested in what do we care
about enough to get up every day
including the bad days and work on and
then also you know where do we think
there's interesting business opportunity
and kind of figure out where the overlap
is and we actually spent about six
months doing that so going through
looking at different ideas talking to
people trying to be smart probably we're
not that smart but trying to be you know
effective at figuring out what was a
good idea right testing by talking to
friends and family by putting up landing
pages all this sort of techniques that
you know every is familiar with but
trying to get that to a good sort of
handle on what was a reasonable business
idea and in part we were trying to do
that to a level of confidence that we
felt good about taking money from
friends and family before we went and
did that and launched the business and
you basically locked yourself in a room
for six months you said you and your
your partner and what was interesting to
me is some of the founders who have
spoken today or spoke today they had
this they kind of had they had a pretty
good brand from the gecko or at least
they had a they knew what they wanted to
be early on whereas you did not start
plate it did not start as plated can you
talk a little bit about the very first
iteration of the product I part of this
was that we were just like broke AF
let's this broke negative yeah but both
so we met in business school which is a
lot of fun but also really expensive and
you know both of us were paying for it
ourselves which is a way of saying the
Citibank was paying for it I think we we
tried did we put it together once we had
something like a quarter million dollars
in debt between the two of us
so you know we had negative money we had
some credit cards that again Citibank
was also paying for that we used to fund
the business so we were just putting
everything on a credit card Nick at
least was married so his wife kind of
supported us in the sense that she was
paying for him and you know we worked
out of their apartment and I ate all
their food but we had no money for
anything including a domain so I think
there was there was two things that we
were doing one was just being cheap
which was by necessity the other thing
was we we were trying to be deliberate
about starting the business and testing
all of the getting although like obvious
big mistakes out of the way before we
you know bought and built the the real
brand we wanted to mess up on a
throwaway brand so we started out with
Dinan fresh calm it's awful it's literal
it's hard a ten dollar domain name yeah
it was available I mean that was the
basic search criteria go on GoDaddy you
what can be buy that isn't you know it's
available right but it's terrible it's
it's it's too literal no good brands are
literal it's everyone you know is it
dining dying in how do you spell that it
was just you know too long too many
syllables etc but it was available and
it was good enough to test on so he ran
on that brand for three months or so
during which he got through a bunch of
milestones we had enough conviction to
take some money from friends and family
all of that turned out to be a lot
harder than we expected it to be we
raised that money enough to go buy
plated which we had to negotiate you
know not surprisingly somebody owned it
they weren't using it so it was you know
reasonably affordable and then build you
know sort of branded any around it and
launched that properly what was the
Dinan fresh period like what were you
doing what in what sense what were we
doing was it it was just a basic landing
page and you're driving traffic there
through white Facebook ads or so it was
a I mean it was a fully functional
website it was ugly as sin
but it was a fully functional ecommerce
site it was taking orders for us that we
were then fulfilling all of it was super
scrappy we were doing it out of Nick's
apartment but it was a site to go to
place orders manager account normal sort
of e-commerce functionality including
you know kind of customer research so I
would sit there on the laptop and chat
with people and asked what they liked or
didn't like her why they were gone
you're just using like an o lark like a
website plug-in that allows you to chat
with anyone who visited the website
exactly and where was the traffic coming
from mostly Facebook in the early days
now I don't know that's that helpful in
today's context but back way back in the
day of 2012 it's funny I say this to
people now I mean we started we
literally filed the incorporation papers
in June of 2012 and the thing that
people don't often remember was that in
May of 2012 Facebook went public like
Facebook was barely a thing then and
they were still basically and in some
cases literally giving away media you
know there was some program you could
sort of apply to and I remember the
mechanics and they would just give you
you know a fifty thousand dollar
advertising credit so you know we were
we were spending we didn't get that
credit by the way but my point is just
Facebook was very very inexpensive so we
were spending five or ten dollars a day
and that was enough to drive you know a
hundred visits or whatever it was enough
that we could do kind of user research
in real time a hundred visits a day
turned out to be what like 20 customers
a week I don't think the conversion rate
was that healthy but something like that
so like tens tens a week tens a month
for your first handful of month or for
three months six months that's about
right yeah probably three to four months
and you're telling me about the early
version of the of the meal kits how how
are you creating the menu I'd tell
everyone how you're preparing the the
food well the the the theme to those
answers and all of them is it was it was
me and Nick doing everything and we
no real experience in hardly anything I
mean I I have a software engineering
background I wouldn't claim myself as a
professional engineer I could do it
enough to build the site and such Nick
was a marine and had some you know
reasonable sort of operations experience
but outside of that call it engineering
and operations we didn't know anything
about anything
you know anything about the culinary
part or the customer acquisition part or
you know anything else so but we had no
resources so we just figured it out
so on the recipes part we were just
writing them or finding them on you know
sites recipes.com wherever you know we
were just we were hacking it together we
were finding recipes we were packing
boxes at first out of his apartment you
know we were just kind of doing whatever
we needed to do to make it work
so you're you're someone places an order
that you have made up the menu you make
it the menu daily or weekly or something
like that weekly and you literally then
just go to Whole Foods or Safeway or
whatever you guys whatever the stores
are up here and you're literally just
individually packing packaging the
ingredients and then taking it to the
post office yeah
we were we were hand fulfilling
everything which I know a lot of you
Congress companies get started that way
just happen to be food but what was the
like let's say you're packing chicken
what was that wrapped up and so on the
packaging front again something we
didn't know anything about we you know
we tried to be smart and certainly
always erred on the side of food safety
but what that meant is you know the
early packaging design was like way too
much you know it's it's an industry
challenge even today you know the amount
of packaging is something that you know
we focus on but back the head like it
was comical I mean you'd get you know a
freaking refrigerator sighs you know
delivery for you know a chicken breast
it was wrapped in a bunch of you know
insulation with ice packs and the sort
of general concept was the same as it is
today but a lot less elegantly and how
long were you doing this out of your
apartment before the apartment piece
only lasted probably three months
you know we pretty quickly but we knew
that that was not scalable it was you
know it was not the right thing to be
doing for a lot of reasons so as quickly
as we could you went out and found a
warehouse space not that but like
everything that took a couple of tries
to get it right but we got out of the
apartment pretty quickly and then so you
guys are bootstrapping the company up
until this point you are in debt are you
paying for all this on a monthly basis
with credit cards or yes so you know
other options I mean we not for lack of
trying we were applying for small
business loans and pitching everybody
and every other you know method that we
could think of to try to get access to
capital but we didn't have any and at
that point like you're applying for
small business loans you just said did
you actually think that this is gonna
scale to something with hundreds of
billions of dollars in value or was it
just man if we can get to like five
hundred thousand dollars a year in
revenue I'll be so happy so we I don't
think we have we really had any sense of
how big that it might get but we did you
know both want it to get very big and
also you know just in working through
this the spreadsheet math which has its
obvious limitations but working through
the spreadsheet math of the business
model it's very clear that I mean
basically all e-commerce business models
like I would say as a rule of thumb most
ecommerce businesses need to be very
large to be breakeven right there's
exceptions to everything and my friends
that have dropship businesses and things
like that that you know that work but by
and large e-commerce is a high fixed
cost low variable cost business so you
gotta sell a ton of units to cover
your your high fixed cost so we thought
they would need to get big and and that
we were gonna have to raise money to get
there so what happened between month
let's say four and an eight I know you
guys raised roughly four hundred
thousand dollars and funding you raised
a little bit of funding what happened
between that period so probably a month
three we had enough confidence to go and
raise money from people now we thought
that was gonna be like you go and pitch
some people and yeah it's hard but we'll
go do it it took us three months and
about 200 pitches to get anybody to say
yes and that first yes was a group of
angels you know to the tune of about 400
grand which today is like a joke of a
seed round I mean most like venture
businesses are raising millions not that
that isn't without its you know downfall
as well but so he raised that four
hundred thousand dollars from a group of
angels and as individuals right people
that have had some success before and
were crazy enough to believe in us and
then bought the plated domain built the
brand went to plan this big launch which
was its own special form of disaster so
building up to the the launch you know
we we were doing what we thought we
should do which is try to get some press
get the website ready get the inventory
in order etc and then go try to get
somebody to write about us so Nick my
co-founder was was doing all the media
at this point went out and got Thrillist
in DC here in Boston to do they're sort
of city specific pieces on us and you
know we get all excited we're thinking
it's just yeah this is gonna be it
they'll write these pieces you know will
be a billion dollars overnight and ride
off into the sunset and about three days
before the launch which was on Monday in
October of 2012 we we start kind of you
know hunkering down to get ready and
figuring out start hearing some noise
about a storm coming and for the folks
that lived here in that time you
probably remember that was when
Hurricane sandy hit so it was literally
overnight Sunday into Monday when that
hit which just obviously devastated the
area no power no internet no you know no
cell phone service in most parts of the
city we came within about three inches
of our or one kind of sad that a
warehouse being flooded out of business
which would have I mean completely
ruined us we had absolutely no you know
backup money at that point survived that
thankfully it's a fun story now in
hindsight but it definitely came very
close to killing the business and then
went off and you know we're able to
continue growing and eventually raise
some venture capital money a sort of
proper institutional
Capital and how long did was that
initial seed round supposed to last or
how long did it last you so I don't
think we really knew how long it was
going to last we were just trying to
stretch it as far as we could you know
we had just been sort of beaten and
battered by the fundraising process and
and you know knew that it was gonna be
hard so we were trying to stretch it as
far as we could I think you know we
probably would have estimated 18 months
of runway it was probably more realistic
more realistically half of that and in
part because once things start working
you know the marketing takes requires
money even though it you know it's
profitable on an roi basis you sort of
you know you pay facebook and then it
takes a few months to kind of make that
money back is is anyone here in the
hustles embassador group oh great a fair
bit of people so I had a long post on
there two or three days ago and I got
frustrated talking to a couple friends
who were trying to recruit a basically a
co-founder to a company and and in this
co-founder they're they're gonna pay the
it was an $80,000 job and people weren't
willing to take that because it was a
huge step back and their current salary
and even though they they said they
wanted to start a company they're like
yeah you know like I'm already getting
paid like 150 you know I don't want to
get paid 80 and it just pissed me off
because that pissed me off but I was
like man I don't think people quite
understand when you start something
you're early
salaries are typically very very low for
me the first year it was roughly like it
came out to be like around 20 or 30
grand and the next year it was a little
bit more than that and now it's
reasonable but you're you're you're
painters all very little early on and
you had that same journey right yeah so
I you know I think it's a it's a it's an
important and somewhat nuanced topic you
know I always feel compelled sort of say
I think that it's a you know a privilege
and I feel privileged to have had the
ability to go do it even with all the
debt
that made it hard and all those things
we still you know I was at a place in my
life I didn't have kids you know I had
friends I had a supportive family I knew
I wasn't gonna be homeless and that
safety net is something that not
everybody has so I think it's important
to acknowledge that because sometimes
these things can get sort of glorified
in a way they shouldn't that said yeah
we didn't pay herself for a long
time you know it was it's a similar kind
of story
you know 20 30 grand first year maybe
you know whatever 30 40 grand the second
year and by the way when you start
running short on money and you can't
make all a payroll you're the first
person that doesn't get paid and that
happened multiple times so you know I
agree I think like it's a reasonable
expectation for somebody starting a
business to you know if you can't do it
you can't do it and that's that's what
it is and that's that's sort of reality
sometimes but raising money I mean I do
some angel investing now and it's it's a
huge red flag but if somebody's trying
to take a big salary out of it like it's
not a good use of them what do you
consider a big salary eighty thousand is
definitely a big salary for you know the
first year of a company I don't know
where I don't know there's a bright line
there but it's it's closer to 20 than 80
yeah I mean I think I think that it's
easy to glorify this entrepreneur
journey but it takes a long time to get
to to get quote market market salaries
you know what I mean and I think that
when you and I were talking I wanted to
bring that up because I don't think that
people understand yeah I I don't think
you know and and there's no sort of one
place you can just sort of look for what
a market salary is but I don't think
that we were paying ourselves to market
salaries until after we sold the
business after five years let's talk a
little bit about some pretty specific
tactics so think basically after after
raising your your second round I mean it
was definitely like a it started to grow
nicely and things were working well you
guys ended up with roughly 1200
employees that things were going well
but what got you those first customers
very very early on
and say the first 9 10 months yeah it
changed very rapidly and I think that's
the real answer to how to go find those
customers I mean it's a common question
and it's an important one and I get why
everybody asks it but at the same time
you know these things are really just
arbitrage it's finding places where you
know the media or the attention of
people is underpriced I mean that's like
in a nutshell what you're looking for
whether it's influencers not that's
exactly a secret anymore or Facebook in
the early days or whatever the sort of
new thing is so what we were doing the
first ever customers were what we talked
about a few minutes ago had a chat
client on the website you'd come on you
get that sort of annoying little pop-up
and you know say hey what can I help you
with and in the very early days it was
just me you know so Nick my co-founder
risk on it was not technical as it was
officer doing everything offline the
media and the operations and all these
things and I was just sitting on a
laptop doing everything there writing
the code for the website doing the
customer service everything in between
and I would just literally sit there and
talk to people on chat and it was very
helpful you know certainly at times kind
of frustrating but I would sit there and
you know I remember the the earliest of
those chats some of them would go for
hours which I still kind of wonder why
people were willing to spend hours
talking to a random person on the other
side of a chat client but they were very
helpful in terms of telling me you know
why did you click on that ad which is on
Facebook generally how they ended up on
the website and then tell me what you
think of the website what you know does
this make sense to you what parts of it
don't are you thinking about buying are
you not like what would it take for you
to buy and then just building that back
into the copy on the website the signup
flow etc in his real time as we could
now that obviously doesn't scale
but over time Facebook in that first you
know two years for us was a big channel
we layered on other things and honestly
the way I always sort of describe this
to you know investors and other people
is
we we did it all in-house customer
acquisition that is and it looks like a
hedge fund trading desk it's all just
sort of arbitrage of you know cost per
click and cost per impressions and
everything else and what are the tactics
that you know other people are not using
yet and every time Facebook have put out
a new tool audience look-alikes whatever
it was it would be great for a month and
then like okay for three more months and
then not work at all after that how did
you figure out what you could spend
early on to acquire a customer we just
tried to be careful is that my best
answer because we you know and again I
think this is very dependent on the
business model most ecommerce businesses
probably ought to be breakeven on the
first order we're a subscription and a
low margin business so we kind of had to
make a bet on how many times you'd order
on what the lifetime value was so we
just tried to be conservative in the
beginning and not shoot ourselves in the
foot and then as we as the business you
know God got older and we started having
more customers or any customers that had
been with the business for months or
years we'd have more you know informed
view what about raising a lot of venture
capital you guys raised 90 million
dollars I asked I we have not raised any
venture capital and and I'm personally I
don't know if I actually want to ever do
that maybe maybe not but when I asked
you that question your your answer was
different than most most entrepreneurs a
venture funded companies which was 100%
absolutely yes I will do it again
whereas most people I talked to say like
maybe and a lot of people say never
again
you said wholeheartedly yes yeah can you
tell me about that decision-making
process and why you're gonna raise money
again in the future
so I think I think it all comes down to
knowing what you want to do it probably
sounds cheesy but you know some business
models require a venture most don't and
I actually think and I I think
a lot of the sort of topics and
businesses that you talk about and cover
are aimed at some of the non venture
which is I think I'm a huge fan of like
I think that that you know kind of
bootstrap businesses or lifestyle
businesses are don't get enough you know
press get a bad rap sometimes like a lot
of my you know like happiest most
content friends are running those kinds
of businesses and so I think that it's
you know that they are equally as
important equally as valuable I mean
probably on average they're more
valuable than mentor businesses right I
mean that's no sort of secret that most
venture businesses fail they're very
binary at sort of a billion dollars or
nothing so this is all you know don't
sort of overweight what I'm saying
some days I wake up and wish that I
wanted to go build something that looked
more like a bootstrap business it's just
all the stuff that I'm I think most
interested in and most and best suited
to build which for me is kind of large
scale technology products those are the
kinds of things I'm most interested in
what I've spent my whole adult life
working in and those tend to be venture
backed you know type businesses where
you need to raise a lot of money to make
it work there is no amount of like you
know hustle that will you know that will
they will allow you to build facebook
without raising a billion dollars like
it just does that is not simply possible
so for me it's a no-brainer which isn't
to say that it's always fun or always
pleasant or anything else I mean having
a big board and a bunch of entry guys to
manage and go out every you know once a
year or once every year and a half to
raise money is a big distraction and has
very real downsides including that it's
no longer your business or just your
business you're gonna sell a bunch of it
you have managing other people's money
etc but for a certain kind of business
there's no option when you guys were
starting out were there a lot of
competitors - someone was asking that on
the screen it's a it seems like a pretty
crowded space now was it like that at
then no is a short answer you know we
were as far as we are aware the first
company in the u.s. there was a company
in Europe at the time that was getting
started you
that they started a bit ahead of us but
we didn't you know we weren't aware of
them it's an interesting thing just you
know sort of waves if companies tend to
get started around the same time there's
something just in the in the media in
the air or whatever it is that a lot of
you know similar types of businesses
started around the same time but it was
not competitive because there was no
scale businesses or was hardly anybody
doing anything you know the sort of
label of food tech didn't exist back
then the closest you know sort of
comparison that anybody had for us was
Webvan which was not a good comparison
we got we were thrown out of I can't
even account how many people's offices I
don't know why they took the meetings in
the first place separate sort of topic
but people would take his meetings and
we'd start pitching and we get you know
90 seconds in they're like wait a second
this is just web and get out of
here it's like okay well thank you but
so no and if you had a start over again
would you start in this space now or is
it too crowded um I don't think today
that I would go start in this space at
least not without a clever idea around
how to differentiate yourself around how
to build an audience you know it's not
clear to me where and it doesn't mean it
enough that these things don't exist I
just I spent my day today running you
know a medium-sized business at this
point not looking at certain new
customer acquisition channels but it's
not clear to me where you go build a big
audience you know in a venture sort of
style through you know paid media
through hyper-growth etc today because
Facebook and Google to some extent was
the way that it rate did that from 2012
to probably 2016 and that's you know
largely gone
what year so you guys were on Shark Tank
what year was that we filmed in the
summer of 2013 so they film it like you
know like a regular TV show as far as I
know anyway I don't know a ton about the
TV industry and then air it throughout
the season so filmed in the summer of 13
the season is you know September to May
or what have you we aired in April of 14
how much traffic did it bring to your
website a huge huge amount like we were
talking I had a friend that was on there
and she said that they had like
a hundred thousand concurrent users at
one point while the show aired is that
what you I think I'll give you the rough
numbers as I remember them and I should
go back and look at these one day but
you know so at the time we were we
probably had you know you pull up Google
Analytics and just look at the you know
concurrent people on the site it was
probably 50 on average if you just sort
of looked at an average week so across
you know 24/7 middle denied middle today
whatever probably fifty people on
average were on the site and back in
shark tank still aired Friday nights so
we had a big party in the office and you
know had TVs up on the walls with Google
Analytics and these sorts of things and
within about three seconds of the
segment starting they went from fifty to
fifty thousand no and then the site
crashed which is bad we had a we had a
you know a backup site just like a
static page like a cloud million thing
yeah it was an email capture page so you
know not like a dynamic ecommerce site
just a flat page you couldn't do
anything other than leave your email
that came up thankfully that lasted six
seconds or something and collected like
13,000 emails and then that crashed so
we were on Heroku if that means anything
to anybody so built on top eight of
Amazon it was our hosting platform a
time they told us it was the single
biggest database like they'd ever seen
and I say that not because it's anything
to do with us I think it's just it's
actually kind of interesting to me that
that a lot of folks still ask and don't
seem to appreciate just like how effing
big shark tank is as a platform when we
were on and I suspect it's gotten bigger
I don't know but when we were on it was
going into 11 million households on
Friday night which is like 10 percent of
the households in the US and that's
before whoo and reruns in syndication
and DVR etc so it's just I mean it's
crazy and they don't they don't take any
cut they don't get like an equity
position in the company just for you
being there or anything like that it's
just free I mean if you say no it's free
they used to so you may have heard that
that's all gone - gone for a long time
it's you know free quote unquote to go
on and then you know you do whatever do
you do with them
a lot of the people who I've been I've
interviewed two other people today
neither of them have ever sold their
business I think you're the first one
I've spoken to today that has when you
were starting this were you going into
this like I'm never gonna sell this I'm
gonna run this forever or I'm only
building to sell which some people which
is great as well
what was your balance of building to
sell versus building to last forever
yeah so I agree both are great
again just sort of like knowing what you
want is a big task but important we
wanted to run it forever so I built two
two software businesses before this and
my business partner had done some other
entrepreneurial things but those those
weren't really big hits were they no no
they were they were much smaller yeah I
learned a ton very worth doing but much
much smaller businesses but the point is
both of us had done enough things in our
life I suppose that we just you know and
maybe who knows we would have maybe
things would have changed but we wanted
to build and run the business
indefinitely you know it was kind of
what we wanted to do we both had some
other jobs that we really didn't like
you know we didn't want to have to go
get another job we didn't necessarily
you know want to go start in their
business I mean there's early days are
hard like I don't think there's any way
around that so we were building it to
run indefinitely the the the sort of
flip side of that though is you know
once you take venture money I mean
really anybody's money but especially
venture money you know that's a that's a
professional agreement to return that
money at some point and they've got
their timelines and if you've never sort
of heard it when you raise money from
somebody their business model becomes
yours you know their timelines their fun
timelines become your timelines and
you've got to give that money back at
some point
and if you and if you don't sort of know
it like it's not just the the silly guy
and the sweater vest it's not his money
it's like teachers pension funds and
real people it's their money so you got
to give it back which means you have to
have some kind of plan for either going
public or selling the business
you can't just stay private forever I
mean there's exceptions to everything
but it's very very difficult to do that
so we wanted to run it forever but we
were also making sure we were building
relationships with the groceries and
things like that
and are there any regrets from selling
it's been over a year do you ever say to
yourself like that was too soon or are
you like that was perfect timing or do
you regret owning it's what you what
used to be yours yeah I don't I don't
know what perfect timing means I don't
regret it
you know it's bittersweet for sure it's
a little like I mean I don't have kids
so this is just what other people have
told me but yeah sort of having kids
that's go off to college or leave the
house or what have you because it's not
ours anymore you know I still I still
run the business day to day but we're
owned by Albertsons which is a big
conglomerate of grocery stores it's
arsons in Safeway and you know 18 other
brands and they're a great partner and
you know we get a lot out of being in
that sort of family of companies but
it's not really ours anymore and
wouldn't whoa when you were starting
this where you were you just looking for
something that something that you were
interested in that could go big I mean
was your interest in building a big
business or was the interest in mostly
[Music]
making sure that people consume healthy
food yeah so that was that was a
question on here I think we could most
because they have a deep passion for the
problem yes so the short answer is yes
we were trying to solve our own problem
both of us had had you know kind of
finance type jobs working a hundred
hours a week and eating seamless you
know literally seven nights a week and
not really loving that and then trying
to cook and trying to eat you know a bit
more fresh food and just having a bunch
of challenges and doing it in a way we
were proud of and it's easy to just you
know sort of buy frozen stir fry kits
but yeah we were both like Nick was
engaged and getting married I was dating
we were trying to you know him press
signa thing other 's and
and just take care of ourselves and we
were having a bunch of challenges that
we thought other people might have as
well which is go to the grocery store we
didn't really know we were doing how
much do i buy what recipe am i making
you know you probably screw that up or
the grocery store doesn't have
everything you're looking for at the end
of the week half of its leftover you
throw it away you feel bad about that
you probably weren't that good of a cook
like it just there was a lot of friction
in that process that we thought you know
we certainly felt and felt that we could
solve for other people and certainly had
a passion for you know the kind of
broader kind of healthy living space and
actually had a you know still do have a
lot of plans for other product lines
that kind of apply to that over time so
you're talking about feeling bad for
throwing food foods away when if you
were to pitch this idea to me years ago
before this was a real thing I would
have said there's no way you're gonna be
able to ship food and it'd still be
healthy I mean everyone says that I mean
everyone's shocked oh my god it still
stays fresh early on you probably didn't
have very nicely insulated boxes I don't
know you probably didn't have all this
the fancy nice stuff that you have now
dry ice aha how are you figuring out how
to get food from New York City to
wherever you're going without going bad
that seems like a huge problem it no
problem it's a it's a challenge for sure
it's probably less of a challenge than
you might think
so I mean that the short answer is it's
not dry ice that's never been dry ice
it's just sort of frozen you know ice
packs that are largely water and
cornstarch but in any case you know we
were buying insulation and there's a
it's reasonably you know sort of
straightforward engineering ways to
figure out that to solve this problem
you know that our factor of the
insulation like the sort of
thermodynamics of it are not that
complicated
so the problem was never really keeping
the food fresh not that it's a hundred
percent but that's not the biggest
problem the biggest problem is
optimizing that sort of customer
experience you know less packaging fully
recycled look cetera and I actually saw
it's up here down a question about sort
of you know waste and these things know
what what's up what was the question
looking at this question here on
recycling and waste and everything else
and yeah that's it that's the next up
question which is recycling it yeah so
it's it's a good question and it's
something that we invest in a lot but I
think it's also worth you know kind of
noting that it's a it's a different
dynamic than most people including my
family who were asking me about it to
seem to really understand it first which
is which is really this the waste you
walk into a grocery store the produce
that's in there first off is older than
you think it is just because of their
supply chain and something like 40% of
that's getting thrown away and by the
way that didn't show up like with farmer
Bob in his bare feet it came on a truck
wrapped in packaging that's just the
reality you don't see it but that's
what's happening so when we try to do
you know kind of apples to apples
comparisons and it's not fully
straightforward to do that you know I
would say and the in the lawyers you
know won't allow me to I sort of make
this claim on the TV commercial or
anything like that but that the milk
industry generally this is not just
plated it's far more efficient than a
grocery store in terms of food waste
because you're throwing away close to
nothing as a consumer of your mule kit
we're throwing away 3% slow single digit
percentages of the food contrasted to 40
percent of the stack of tomatoes and
that grocery store down the street being
thrown away before you ever see them and
then you're gonna buy them and probably
throw away half that's about the
consumer average nationally as 50% of
the fresh food that you buy gets thrown
away sure everybody's had some version
of that experience you open your fridge
on Sunday and like well this is all
rotten so on the food waste piece the
industry is you know probably a lot more
efficient on the packaging and the
transportation you know we're probably
less efficient because we're packaging
you know individual portions rather than
big portions but it's very hard to tell
if that
you know it is net-net actually any less
sort of impactful and it's you know you
kind of get into a lot of like wonky
math around transportation and you know
with the lettuce coming from California
is it not is it how did it get here
you know truck miles etc etc but I guess
net-net it's something we care about
we're working on but I think the state
of it all is different than is maybe you
know a parent of people at what point in
in the company's existence did all these
competitors come come around I don't
know it's a gradual process you know I
mean a couple of them started in the
first year or two you know I think we
we've done a lot of competitive research
over the years and I'm very confident
that there's really only ever been six
companies that had any real scale so
there's been a lot of you know small
companies most of them failed to my
earlier point you know it's not really a
business that you can run profitably yet
small scale so most of the competitors
have kind of come and gone and you know
and I think this is actually a pattern
not a coincidence all six of those
started with in the first call it two
years of the industry and I think beyond
that it was a sort of playing field was
largely established and you had a lot of
kind of long tail companies it entered
and exited but nobody started sort of
year three or after and got big so when
you guys you guys were all starting out
around the same time you've all scaled
together when that's going on it's a
dogfight for customers right I mean it's
it's it you're going head to head with
somewhat what you said five others six
other people how ha what was your plan
to to beat the other person to survive
to win and how are you being different
from others yeah so you know again this
will this this may sound cheesy but I
believe it the the point from for our
business and I think for a lot of
consumer you know type businesses not
all it's not true for you know probably
Facebook but for most businesses I think
you should just ignore the competition
you know it's about understanding who
your customer is and serving that
customer
and as long as you're in a big enough
market the company will succeed you know
when I was raising money the example we
would use all the time is Chipotle
Chipotle is basically lunch they do a
little bit of business at dinner but
it's mostly lunch and it's you know
mostly one product there's six
ingredients or whatever the count is and
yet that business does end and by the
way they're you know they're not
national they're in lots of places I
don't know exactly how many zip codes
but they're not in every ZIP code in the
country and it's a four billion dollar
revenue business and there's national
competitors and regional ones and local
ones and the bodegas in the corner and
everything else and they still do four
billion dollars top line like the point
is not are they stealing customers from
somebody else the point is do you
understand your customer and serve them
well and you know we looked at lots of
examples and food like that I mean the
grocery stores are in some ways a
similar kind of story you know you know
pick your favorite grocery store I
promise you that's a big business I mean
Albertsons a sixty billion dollars top
line and probably a lot of people in
this room have never been into another
students so our our kind of internal
mantra not that we always were
successful at following it was the
Amazon mantra focus on the customer let
the customer root or they let the
competitors sort of you know figure that
out to them on their own so we only got
a minute and a half two minutes left I
want to talk about something that hasn't
been addressed and I saw the question on
here which is about co-founder
relationships how long did you know your
partner before you guys became partners
and what was there there had to be but
what were some of the breaking points
and how did you guys resolve those
issues so we knew each other for four
years before and my other two businesses
I also started with friends I think it's
a it's kind of a high-risk high-reward
strategy if you will when it works
there's nothing in the world better than
you know winning as a team and winning
with your friends when it doesn't work
is probably nothing worse than losing a
friend over
overwork but the way that and and I had
a version of that in my first business I
was 21 when I did it had no idea what I
was doing probably still don't know what
I'm doing but really had no idea back
then and the the sort of co-founder
relationship went sideways and you know
it was not not good and I say I say now
the people that I'm happy I kind of
learned that lesson early in life but
the way that I thought about it was a
friend and a friend that I could do you
know hard stuff with not just a drinking
buddy but somebody that I could work
with and Nick and I I don't think we
knew we were doing it at the time but we
we had some trial runs at that we did
some volunteering in Haiti where we were
quite literally sleeping on a concrete
slab with mosquito nets and you know
like physically hard mentally hard stuff
that kind of proved to us at least in
hindsight as we were making the decision
to work together that we could do it and
then the last piece and I'll shut up but
we had complementary skills that's not
the same and I think that's important
because that's another one of the kind
of common challenges I've seen people
run into is you know you get two people
who have the exact same bank rent you
know background we worked whatever it
doesn't matter worked at the same
company together we're friends we're
gonna go do this and we do the exact
same things like okay well how are you
gonna figure out who does what and you
know only one person can run marketing
only one person can run engineering etc
and at some point like that's gonna
cause a problem so for us it was we're
friends we can work together and we have
you know complementary skill sets Nick
was not technical I was he was a marine
he was better at the operations better a
lot of that stuff and it just worked and
it's not to say we didn't fight I think
that's just part of human relationships
but it worked well in last last question
with the quick answer Josh seven years
ago six years ago wanting to start
something in today's era you know what
would you say like don't make this
mistake what mistake would you try to
tell them to to avoid oh man here so
there's a lot of them but maybe I'll
just I'll pick you know solve a real
problem I see too many people do
where you know they try to start
something because there's some nifty new
technology or you know that the business
model is too clever or whatever if you
can't describe the real problem its
solving for a real person very quickly
it's probably not a good idea although
half the fun of this stuff is there's
exceptions to everything and somebody in
here will prove me wrong gosh thank you
very much we really appreciate you
taking the time thank you thank you
[Applause]